the I get inspiration from a lot of
things part of my inspiration is just
the desire to make something special and
being inspired by special music that
I've heard before from people like
Marvin Gaye or Jeff Buckley or Nina
Simone or the Beatles or Stevie Wonder
you know people that I've looked up to
for years they inspire me because they
let me know what greatness sounds like
and I aspire to that every time I make a
record and you know I still feel like
I'm reaching for those goals and I'll
always keep reaching for those where you
can make something that's really you
know that can transcend that can you
know take you to some other place only
certain music is able to do that only
certain grade artists have been able to
do that and that's what I aspire to I
think those artists that have done that
for me are my inspiration
you